gabriel jean marie bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes candidat de combat ouvrier
lutte ouvrière pour les législatives à
fort de france qu'est ce qui motive
votre candidature
ce qui motive notre candidature c'est
que les travailleurs doivent avoir leur
revoir leur politique leurs exigences
défendues dans le cadre de cette
campagne de l'élection législative
de corps qu'est ce que vous espérez
capite une partie du vote anti macron
qui s'est exprimé lors de la
présidentielle à nous n'espérons pas
capté nous espérons nous appelons
simplement les travailleurs à se
prononcer sur un programme qui défend
leurs intérêts
c'est tout un et ce programme là il se
décline en trois points sur le chômage
nous disons que pour lutter contre ce
fléau il faut une répartition du travail
entre tous
nous disons que
pas de salaire pas de pension de
retraite pas d'allocation inférieurs à
2000 euros net par mois parce que c'est
ce qu'il faut pour vivre et puis le
troisième point c'est que nous défendons
le principe de l'abolition des secrets
bancaires industrielles commerciales
voilà ce sont les exigences le monde du
travail d'année en année ce sont les
mêmes thèmes que vous développez est ce
qu'à un moment vous devez pas ce qu'on
ne devait pas changer votre fusil
d'épaulé pour avoir un peu plus
d'électeurs n'ont pas du tout nous ne
sommes pas à la chasse aux électeurs
nous sommes simplement là pour défendre
les intérêts effectivement du monde du
travail de quoi parle-t-on surtout ces
jours ci nous parlons de salaires bas
nous disons nous entendons que comment
faire pour vivre avec avec ta vie chère
les prix qui augmentent les carburants
les denrées alimentaires nous entendons
beaucoup parler du chômage mais il faut
du travail pour tous il y a des gens qui
coule sur le chômage et pays y en a
d'autres qui vivent
vous avez entendu certainement tout ce
qui est dit concernant les futurs
les futures dispositions qu'on voudrait
prendre macron concernant les ceux qui
perçoivent des indemnités d'allocations
chômage le rsa donc ce sens ce sont des
thèmes d'actualité oui le président
justement ma cour a lancé des projets et
à lancer des territoires g20 chômage
vous riez vous rigolez pourquoi bah
écoutez ce sont des promesses qui sont
fait qu'ils sont lancés un aléa comme ça
mais on sait très bien que ce ne sont
pas ces politiques qui sont responsables
justement de cette flambée du chômage de
cette flambée des prix qui vont régler
les problèmes ça n'est pas vrai ce sont
des pyromanes il met le feu et puis le
disent qu'ils vont les thèmes ça n'est
pas vrai sur veut
les les retraites il ya aussi beaucoup à
dire il y a beaucoup pas dire il y a
beaucoup à dire notamment avec cette
volonté de d'allonger la durée de
cotisation
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une pension de
retraite mais est ce que ce n'est pas à
la limite j'ai envie de dire ce que ce
n'est pas normal de penser allongés
parce qu'on vit plus longtemps oui en
vie plus longtemps mais en produit plus
la productivité est beaucoup plus
importante donc dire qu'on va allonger
la durée de cotisation parce qu'on vit
plus longtemps non justement
quand on voit que les que les organismes
de gauche se sont réunis vous comment
vous voyez là nubes sauver la nuque
comment quel regard vous avez sur cette
union écoutez je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire gauche
d'accord lorsque jo pour la composition
de ce gouvernement macron depuis 2017
lorsque je vois tout ce que ça a donné
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
gauche non plus sérieusement
on entend beaucoup de formules d'hommes
de femmes prêts
providentiel je dirais qu'ils veulent
apporter des solutions en tout ces
personnes à un niveau ou à un autre à un
moment un autre dans un gouvernement
dans un autre on pas anticipé ont créé
cette situation donc ce sont simplement
des alliances électorales qui sont
faites rien d'autre aucun espoir
rien d'autre sinon le saurait depuis
longtemps d'accord ensuite quelles sont
les autres thèmes que vous allez
développer sur pendant cette
candidature pendant cette campagne bah
écoutez ce sont les points que nous
avons que j'ai cités déjà au départ un
ce sont ces trois principaux points le
fléau du chômage donc il faut répartir
le travail entre tous sans baisse de
salaire un salaire en revenus nets pas
en mois de deux mille euros et puis la
levée de la position d'israël toupie
qu'on va le vu son revenu net par mois
de 2000 euros ah ben non ça n'est pas
utopique parce que je fais remarquer une
joueuse de mélenchon a pas du tout et je
vais vous dire que il est même très loin
de nous je vais vous faire remarquer
qu'il n'ya pas longtemps il y à un
organisme qu on ne peut pas qualifier
d'extrême gauche qui a dès qu' il
manquait je crois 490 euros au dessus du
smic pour qu'on puisse vivre
ça se rapproche plus des deux mille
euros que nous pourrons nous réclamons
depuis déjà des années gabriel jean
marie je vous remercie merci
[Musique]